es ist soweit die ersten detaillierten
aufnahmen von dem weitest entfernten je
aus der nähe fotografierte objekt und
genau diese aufnahmen wird es jetzt zu
sehen geben wie sieht ein solches objekt
im pulver gürtel dem asteroidengürtel
rund um unser sonnensystem auf 6,4
milliarden kilometer entfernt und das
ist eine absolute weltpremiere jetzt war
klicks und science und fiction geht es
täglich faszinierendes 1 videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts herzlich willkommen jetzt ist
die große frage ist was ist das für ein
seltsames objekt wir haben es gestern
berichtet beim vorbeiziehen an sterne
machte das objekt etwas sehr seltsames
das ist rund 30 kilometer lang und hat
eine sehr seltsame form das wurde 2017
und 2018 festgestellt mit zahlreichen
teleskopen wurde dabei die flugbahn von
ultima thule beobachtet oder wie die
korrekte bezeichnung ist 2014 360 es ist
allerdings so weit von der sonne
entfernt dass es kein licht reflektiert
allerdings verdeckt es immer wieder
sterne und dabei wurde festgestellt dass
sie nicht einfach hält und wieder
dunkler werden sondern abgedunkelt
werden dann wieder etwas heller werden
dann wieder etwas dunkler und dann erst
wieder endgültig hält ultima thule muss
also eine form wie zwei aneinander
hängende kugeln oder etwas ähnliches
haben und so haben sich das die grafiker
vorgestellt und jetzt ist das verrückte
herausgekommen die damals vermutete form
ist exakt die echte ist das erste mal
dass ein objekt entdeckt wurde dass auf
solch zwei exakten kugeln besteht und
das erklärt auch ein paradoxon von
ultima thule als ich nur horizon nämlich
jetzt näherte stellte die sonne etwas
sehr seltsames fest ultima thule machte
etwas unerwartet dass statt wie bei
unregelmäßigen objekten licht
unregelmäßig zu reflektieren
passiert das nicht doch new horizons
konnte das rätsel heute noch besser
lösen ultima thule dreht sich sehr
speziell und rotiert wie ein propeller
zeigt uns also immer dieselbe seite und
das von zwei kugeln
damit ist die reflektion immer gleich
damit ist das erste rätsel jetzt noch
besser gelöst es ist also in mancher
hinsicht eine sensation ein solches
objekt in einer solchen entfernung wurde
noch nie aus der nähe beobachtet und es
hat eine absolut spektakuläre form und
es gibt schon eine theorie wie das
objekt im stau
sein könnte zahlreiche kleine eis
haltige objekte könnten zuerst
umeinander gekreist sein und am ende gab
es die beiden großen objekte die dann
aufeinander gefallen sind die
gravitation der beiden objekte
obwohl sie mit ein paar kilometern sehr
klein sind reicht aus so das
forschungsteam um sie einander zu binden
genauso so das forschungsteam kann man
sich die entstehung der ersten planeten
vorstellen ultima thule ist damit quasi
eine zeitmaschine an den anfang unseres
sonnensystems ein absoluter glücksfall
für die forschung ist dieses
spektakuläre objekt in der
pressekonferenz die soeben zu ende
gegangen ist hieß es das wird unser
wissen revolutionieren und heute gibt es
noch eine spektakuläre video premiere
auf unserem englischen kanal vom co2 new
wave technologie max caroline klein mit
friendly dafür hier draufklicken und
anschauen und natürlich abonnieren zu
tun
stay tuned